ils ne veulent pas que l'agression
restent impunis et demande à être
informés des suites de l'enquète les
habitants du quartier saint-jacques de
beaune se rassemblent depuis 18h en
soutien aux victimes de l'agression du
30 juillet dernier
gabrielle talon bonsoir vous êtes sur
place est-ce que cet appel a été suivi
et bien fans ils sont entre 150 et 200 1
réunis derrière moi ici sur les lieux
même de l'agression
ce sont principalement et bien des
habitants du quartier à des familles
venues pour se retrouver et discuter
entre eux il y a également et bien alain
suguenot le maire de beaune qui est
présent il faut dire que cette affaire a
suscité une très vive émotion dans ce
quartier saint jacques
je vous propose est bien de regarder ce
rappel des faits il est signé marie joly
dans la nuit du 29 au 30 juillet une
voiture fonce sur un groupe de jeunes
mais ils n'arrivent pas à les atteindre
trois heures plus tard vers 4 heures du
matin un second véhicule arrive sur les
lieux
le passager sort alors un fusil de
chasse blessent cette jeune majeur
touché par des impacts de plomb
dès le lendemain les victimes prennent
la parole et disent ne pas connaître
leurs agresseurs d homme de type
européen
j'ai vu alors à leur regard qu'ils
avaient une haine envers nous et le pire
c'est les propos comme quoi qu'on était
des [__] et qu'on avait rien à
faire dans ce pays et que c'était qu'ils
allaient revenir calibrer les victimes
évoquent clairement un mobile raciste
mais ont l'impression que leur parole
est remise en cause par les autorités
depuis les habitants du quartier vivent
dans la crainte et attendent des
réponses
aucune interpellation pour le moment
gabriel est ce que l'on sait comment
avance ils enquêtent et bien nous avons
pu joindre par téléphone cet après midi
le procureur de la république adjoint de
dijon thierry bas nous indique que l'
enquête avance à grands pas et il croit
un dénouement rapide les avancées de
l'enquète lui permettent également
aujourd'hui pour la première fois de
dire eh bien qu'il exclut en fait la
piste du règlement de comptes entre les
victimes et leurs agresseurs
il faut dire et bien que des voix
s'étaient élevées ces certaines
associations pour reprocher à la justice
une difficulté à reconnaître le
caractère raciste de cette agression ce
n'est pas du tout et bien l'état
d'esprit du rassemblement qui est
organisée ici aujourd'hui par les
habitants du quartier
je vous propose d'ailleurs d'écouter
bien le père d'une victime qui est
toujours hospitalisé et un de leurs
avocats
ce qui nous préoccupe c'est les blessés
c'est les gens qui sont touchés
c'est les voisins c'est le quartier mais
tout ce qui est justice moi je fais
confiance à la justice
ils font leur travail très bien avoir de
l'enquêté les investigations les choses
se resserrent et nul doute que le
parquet de dijon choisira la
qualification la plus pertinente la
qualification pénale qui englobera tous
les aspects des faits y compris y
compris l'aspect la connotation raciste
si vous voulez qu'il s'agisse d'une
connotation qui touche le mobile ou les
faits annexes périphériques type
insultes racistes ou autre vous le voyez
derrière moi le rassemblement est
toujours en cours
un rassemblement est bien paisible et
conviviale finalement à l'image de ce
qu'était la vie de ce quartier avant la
triste nuit du 29 juillet